Communication is critical to success in
your professional and personal lives.
This idea has served as the guiding
principle of our show ever since we
started. And today, we are thrilled to
be celebrating our 300th episode with a
special Ask Matt Anything. My name is
Matt Abrahams, and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to Think
Fast, Talk Smart the podcast.
>> [music]
>> It's hard to believe that this is our
300th episode. I want [music] to start
by thanking each and every one of you
for listening and viewing our show. We
work really hard to bring you great
content through our show and social
media. And we truly appreciate your
input and helping us spread the word.
For this episode, we wanted to hear from
you and help with your communication
issues and challenges. We recorded this
live a few weeks back. I start with a
quick lesson about a structure I find
myself using more and more. And then we
move into questions from listeners
around the globe. And as a special
treat, I begin with questions from some
of our amazing team that help bring you
[music] the show. So without further
ado, let's get started. This is our
300th
episode.
We are excited that you are here and we
are thrilled that you take the time to
listen to Think Fast, Talk Smart.
Before I get started taking your
questions, I would love to share a new
favorite structure of mine.
You are all very familiar with the fact
that
uh I love structure. Structure is
nothing more than a logical way of
putting your points forward.
We have all heard of my favorite
structure, three questions. What? So
what? Now what? This structure is very
useful for lots of situations. You can
use it when you're giving feedback, when
you're giving an update, when you're
introducing yourself. This structure is
very useful for educating and informing.
A new structure that I find myself
relying on a lot as I have to articulate
a point of view or defend a position is
one I learned from a lawyer friend of
mine, PREP. Point, reason, example,
point. This is a great structure to use
when you have to put forth an idea, when
you have to support something that
you're advocating for. It works very
simply. You make a point, you give a
rationale or reason supporting that
point, give a concrete example. We tend
to remember concrete examples far better
than high-level information, and then we
return to the point. So, point, reason,
example, point. Let me share with you an
example that in the classes I teach at
Stanford's Business School we like to
use as a way of getting practice with
this. And I assign my students to defend
one side of this argument. So, some are
for it and some are against it. So, the
issue is is a burrito sushi? So, how
would you support that? If you wanted to
support it, you might use PREP. So,
let's walk through this one part at a
time.
The point is a burrito is technically a
type of sushi. The reason, both are
fundamentally seasoned rice fillings
tightly together in an edible
cylindrical wrapper. An example, a
burrito wraps meat and rice in a
tortilla, while sushi is fish and rice
wrapped in seaweed. So, I would then
restate my point, thus a burrito is
technically a type of sushi. And in so
doing, I have made a clear, concise
point. So, I challenge each of you to
think about how you could use prep. I'm
going to give all of you a little
homework. The other issue that we debate
in my class is, is soup cereal? How
would you defend that if you were to use
prep? Point, reason, example, point.
So, now you have another structure to
add to your toolkit of structures. Goes
right next to what, so what, now what.
But, before I take time to take your
questions, I want to introduce you to a
few members of our team. This is our
300th episode, and we work really hard
to bring you the best in podcasting and
the best in careers and communication
advice. And while you get to see and
hear me, there is an amazing team behind
the scenes that brings this all to you.
So, I thought it would be really fun to
start our Q&A with some Q&A from the
team. So, it is my honor and privilege
to invite to the screen Catherine Reed.
Cat is our executive producer and the
brains behind all of what you hear and
see. Cat, how are you doing?
>> I'm good. How are you, Matt?
>> I'm doing great. I love these live
events.
You have a question, I'd love to hear
your question.
>> Yes.
Very glad to be with you on this special
occasion, and thank you to all that were
able to join. So, my question is about
word recall.
>> Mhm.
>> Um, I find for myself there are many
times during conversations or
discussions when I know that there's a
specific word that I want to use, but I
can't quite seem to retrieve it in the
moment. Sometimes I'll pause and I'll
give myself some grace and say something
like, "What's the word I'm looking for?"
to buy myself a little time. So, my
question is, do you have advice for
improving word recall in those moments
or strategies for retrieving the right
word when it just feels like it's out of
reach?
>> Well, I appreciate that question as
somebody who's getting older, uh
retrieval of information of any kind is
is getting challenging. Uh the first
thing I would suggest, Kat, is that as
you think about this, there really is no
right word. There are certainly better
words than others. So, sometimes what
makes it hard to retrieve a word is you
have this word in mind, and then you
say, "Oh, I want to say that right
word." And then that puts added pressure
to yourself. So, I really like the fact
that you take a pause, take a beat, take
perhaps a deep breath in that moment.
And when you take the pressure off of
yourself of saying the right word,
actually it might come more easily. So,
the first thing is to not make it harder
on yourself by adding to your anxiety
level. The next piece has to do with
practice, the way we practice. Now, we
don't want to memorize, we don't want to
make sure that every word is exactly the
way we wanted to say it. That adds extra
pressure. But, through repetition, those
words become more comfortable and easy
to retrieve. That's what practice is
doing. It's actually laying down the
neural pathways that make fluency,
processing fluency, easier for you. So,
part of it is is the practice and the
prep, again, not to memorize, but just
to get familiar with. And then the
second part is when you have that missed
moment, don't put too much pressure on
yourself, take a deep breath, and I hope
that word will come. And I, Kat, as
somebody who talks to you many times
every day, have found that you use
expert language, and I've never noticed
anything other than that. So, thank you
for your question, I appreciate it.
Well, you've got to meet Kat, our
executive producer. I'd like for you to
meet another one of our absolutely
instrumental and important colleagues
here at ThinkFest Talks and Smart. I'd
love for you to meet Neil McFedran. Neil
and I have been working together almost
since the inception of the show. Neil,
thanks for being with us, and I'd love
to hear what question you have.
>> Thanks, Matt. Great to join you here.
So, Matt, I my question's about the a
moment as well, like cats, but a
different moment. So, I'm curious about
those first 5 seconds, if you will, of
public speaking. That exact moment when
it just feels like all the eyes suddenly
turn to you. So, in fact, I just had
one, or one second I was sitting here
listening, and next thing I'm popped up
on everyone's screen, asked this
question. So, so I guess whether it's
joining a Zoom presentation, suddenly
boom, you're the focus, or walking out
onto that stage after being introduced,
and the applause stops, and there's that
instant where I for me it feels like
I've just jumped into cold water. So,
what are your favorite strategies for
handling that surge of adrenaline, like
settling your nerves, and ultimately
starting those first few seconds
strongly?
>> Uh somebody has listened to a few of our
shows, Neil. Uh thank you for that
question. And that And that moment right
before you start, what I call
commencing, is really powerful for many
people, and can be very anxiety-fraught.
So, it's something we we we really need
to think about. So, let me share a few
things about that moment. One, as we
practice, as we prepare, which is really
important to do, we can think about that
moment, knowing that that moment might
be difficult for us. We can desensitize
ourselves to that moment. So, we think
about what it would be like, we can
actually visualize the experience, and
then think about how we might adjust and
adapt in advance. So, having that
contingency plan ready to go, one, can
allow us to invoke it when need be, and
two, just the fact that we know we have
something to do if we get that surge of
adrenaline in that moment, that can
actually reduce its intensity just by
knowing that we have something to do.
So, part of it is the preparation. When
that moment hits, I want to walk you
through three steps. When it comes to
dealing with anxiety, we uh around
speaking, we need to think of the ABCs.
Affect, that's feeling.
B is for behavior, how you
physiologically feel. And then C is for
cognition. And we can do a management
technique for each. So, let's start with
the A. That emotion you feel might be
dread, might be fear. In that moment,
just remind yourself that it's normal
and natural. Most people, and I mean
like 85% of people, have that surge of
anxiety that you're talking about, Neil.
So, recognizing that it's normal and
natural can help. And when you do that,
you you acknowledge it, you actually
give yourself a little bit of space and
agency, so you can do something in that
moment. A great thing to do is to remind
yourself that this normal and natural to
feel anxious and it actually is a sign
that this is important to you and
valuable. And you can get excited about
something that's important and valuable.
As you well know, Neil,
frequent guest of our show is Alison
She did some groundbreaking research
well quite a while back now that said if
you reframe your anxiety as excitement,
not only do you feel better, but you
actually perform better. So, in that
moment, the affect piece, acknowledge,
"Hey, this is me feeling nervous. Makes
sense I'm nervous. Most people would be,
and that's a sign that I should be
excited about this." In terms of
behavior in that moment, 5 seconds, 10
seconds before you start, best thing you
can do is take a deep belly breath. It's
going to slow your heart rate down. It's
going to calm down those nerves. Make
sure your exhale is twice as long as
your inhale. It is all in the exhale
that the magic happens.
And then finally, from a cognitive point
of view, often in those few moments
before we start speaking, we say a lot
of negative things to ourselves. I'm not
prepared. I should have done more. Why
am I doing this? Why isn't this other
person doing it? Instead, let's replace
that with something positive. A positive
affirmation, a positive mantra. Doesn't
have to be I'm the best speaker ever.
Could be something simple. This is what
I do before I speak and I get nervous
and I still do get nervous in some
situations. I simply say I have value to
bring.
I have something of value to the person
or people that I'm speaking to. So, if
you take an ABCs approach, first you
prepare. So, you think about what will
what will I do if I have that
experience? And then ABC, the the
affective part, it's normal and natural.
Typical for somebody to get nervous in
this situation.
B, do some deep breathing, that's for
the behavioral piece. And C, for the
cognition, re- reframe it and see it
through the lens of some kind of
affirmation or mantra. If you do those
things, you'll be better off. Thanks,
Neil, and I'm glad everybody got to meet
you and Cat. So, let's see, we've got
some questions coming in. First
question's from Ethiopia. Wow, hello,
hello. I talk a lot about tell the time,
don't build the clock. Yet, on the other
hand, uh I will often say that listeners
tend to remember specifics more than
generalities. So, I find those two
concepts contradictory. How can you make
sure that you're concise and clear, and
at the same time give detail? This uh is
a great question, because it is a
contradiction, right? It is a a little
bit confusing. How can we be concise but
detailed at the same time? So, this is a
trade-off. And there are a number of
trade-offs that we have to make whenever
we communicate. We want to be specific
and detailed, but we also want to be
clear and concise. So, the question then
becomes, how much detail do I give?
And it really depends on your audience
and the emotional impact you're trying
to have. So, if I am trying to really
motivate, impress upon you how important
this is, I might spend a little bit more
time giving detail, because in that
emotional experience you'll have of my
detail, you are focusing in a way that
you don't if I'm just relaying facts. If
I'm just walking through, let's say,
some financial data or some technical
data, where there isn't as much emotion.
So, it really depends on what your goal
is in terms of the engagement you want.
If you want engagement that's deep and
perhaps emotional, over index, spend a
little more time giving detail, which
means you won't be as concise. If you're
giving details that are devoid or or
don't have a lot of emotions, then I
might really fixate on being concise and
clear to allow me to get to a point in
my communication where I do want to
bring emotion. So, I I really appreciate
the deep thinking that you had there in
terms of the advice that I give. It is a
tension between concision and depth, and
you have to find your best way of
navigating that, and I and I believe it
has to do with who you're speaking to
and the emotion you want to engage.
Thank you so much for that question.
Really insightful. I appreciate it.
All right, our next question. Uh with a
growing reliance on AI for
summarization, email drafts, slides, how
do you ensure our cognitive and
linguistic skills remain sharp? Oh, wow.
This is something that I have been
spending a lot of my time recently
thinking about. Uh AI is fundamentally
changing the way we communicate. And in
fact, I believe that AI is actually
making face-to-face, spontaneous,
in-the-moment communication even more
important.
And it's more important because that's
how we authentically connect. In theory,
AI can polish and in some cases perfect
our communication,
but it makes it more restrictive and
blunts its emotion and reduces some of
its connection. So,
part of that is that we offload our
cognitive effort to the AI tool. We
don't have to think as much. And
communication and critical thinking are
intimately related. You can't
communicate well without critically
thinking, and you can't critically think
without being able to communicate well.
And as we offload some of that critical
thinking burden, we ultimately, I fear,
lessen our skills. And we're starting to
see this. We're starting to see this.
Some recent research came out that says
people are speaking less. We're just
saying less. Part of what AI does is it
increases
concision. So, we we speak less.
People's language and words are starting
to become compressed. In other words,
we're more we're sounding more the same
because we're relying on the same tools.
That's all just proof points to say that
AI does have an impact on our
communication. So, how do we make sure
to leverage AI for the many benefits it
can bring to us and not suffer some of
the consequences? Well, it has to do
with when we use it and how we use it. I
think AI is a great tool to help you
think through your audience, to use it
as a thought partner in terms of
different ways of arguing and
structuring content, but do not rely on
it to make all the decisions for you,
and to create the content
instead of you actually thinking through
it yourself. So, use it as you would,
let's say, a partner, or if you're a
manager, as you might use an intern,
somebody to help you, but not to do the
work for you. Because if we outsource it
all the way, we actually lose some of
the most precious communication skills
that we have. So, thank you for that
insightful question. This is an issue
that I have been thinking about a lot,
and you highlight both the value of AI
and some of the downsides.
Let's see.
In my work, I find that storytelling is
important for sharing information with
others rather than academic teaching. Do
you have any takeaways for storytelling?
Oh, storytelling is so important. First,
human beings are storytelling machines.
We are wired for story. Long before we
had the written word, our species
communicated information through
stories. Think about folklore, legends.
We're wired for story. So, if we can tap
into that, we can be much more
successful. Stories engage and connect.
So much so that when I tell a story, my
brain waves and your brain waves sync
up. It's called cognitive entrainment.
And in some cases, when you look at the
neurological feedback, you can't tell
who is telling the story versus who is
receiving it. The question becomes, how
do we learn to become good storytellers?
I hope this show, Think Fast Talk Smart,
provides some of the very important
tools to do that. We've done several
episodes on storytelling. We did one
with Matthew Dicks. We did a whole
mini-series
on storytelling from people who have
non-traditional storytelling jobs. Think
of a lawyer. Think of a magician. Lots
of different situations where people
tell stories, and we really try to
dissect them. So, it is a skill. It is a
skill you can learn. And everybody has
to develop their own style around
storytelling. A great way to get started
is to think about stories in your life,
things that have happened. Create a
catalog of stories that you have
experienced or that you have seen, and
begin to refine them. Think about how
can I add detail, emotion, make it
relatable to people. How can I start it
in a way that's engaging? So, it is a
process. It's a process you have to
practice. Another great way to get good
at storytelling is just listen to other
people's stories. Find people that you
really admire who tell good stories. And
begin to dissect, what do they do? Do
they start at the beginning or do they
start in the middle and then bring you
back to the beginning? Do they use a lot
of descriptive words? Do they lead with
emotion? All of these are really
interesting tools that you can deploy to
be a better storyteller. I encourage all
of you to work on your storytelling
skills and please please consider Think
Fast, Talk Smart as a good resource for
that. If you go to our website
fastersmarter.io
and you go to the resources page, you'll
actually see some playlists that talk
through stories and how to tell good
stories. So thank you for that question.
All right, let's see. From San Diego,
one of my favorite places. It's gorgeous
in San Diego. Thank you. How do you know
when to use lingo to relate with your
audience
and to avoid jargon? Yeah, this is a
really again a tricky tension that we
have. Sometimes using specific
terminology, lingo as you say, can
actually demonstrate your competence. I
know the insider language.
I know the expected language. They you
know people of my skill and background
should be able to use these terms.
The problem is if you use too much of it
or you use that that terminology with
others who aren't in the know or don't
have the experience you do, then it tips
into jargon and jargon is wording that
it can be distancing.
One of my colleagues, he's been on the
show twice, Huggy Rao. Huggy likes to
talk about jargon monoxide. It
suffocates communication. So we want to
avoid using lingo, technical speak,
acronyms just for the use of them. They
should serve a purpose. So if the
purpose is to demonstrate competence, to
connect with your audience on a deep
level because they know the terms well,
then I would suggest using those terms.
But if you think someone in the audience
might not be aware or they don't have
the depth of knowledge, at the very
least define your terms. Maybe you show
them on a slide. Maybe you spell them
out the first time you use them.
There is more reputational risk, I
believe, in using jargon terminology
people don't know, than there is
reputational advantage to using lingo
that people do know. I think you are set
farther back by using jargon than you
are put farther ahead by using
appropriate lingo. So, I'd like to
introduce more of our team members who
work tirelessly behind the scenes to
help bring Think Fast, Talk Smart to you
twice a week, every week. Kylie, I'd
love to have you join me on screen.
Kylie helps with so many facets of how
we make our show work for all of you.
Welcome, Kylie. I know you've got a
question for me, would love to hear it.
>> Hi, Matt. Nice to see you here.
>> Yes.
>> I have a question about high-emotion
situations. As a leader, I sometimes
feel very nervous before difficult
one-on-one conversations with employees,
especially when I need to ask a hard
question or give constructive feedback
where they could potentially get
emotional. How do I stay calm before and
during the moment, make sure I actually
deliver my point, while still addressing
the situation clearly, but showing care?
>> Well, so Kylie, just so you all know,
Kylie is a very empathetic and kind
person, and and that's demonstrated in
your question because it often as a
leader we have to give constructive
feedback, we have to give direction that
might be challenging for those that are
reporting to us. It's really
appropriate to be concerned about their
emotions, but also your emotions. So, if
this is a circumstance where you
actually get to plan it out in advance,
then I would be thinking through not
just the messaging.
One of the many structures that we
cover, what so what now what is a great
way to give feedback. What is the
feedback, so what is why it's important,
now what is is what you'd like the
person to do differently. So, thinking
through the structure, maybe even
practicing vocalizing it can help, but
also thinking through the emotions that
you might feel in that moment and really
think through
what this might be like for you.
Anxiety, maybe there's a little bit of
frustration with the person. By
cataloging and thinking about those
emotions first, that can help you come
up with a contingency plan. And then
remind yourself, your job as a leader,
as a manager, is to help your team
succeed and to help your employees
succeed. And part of that is actually
giving constructive feedback. So, taking
the time to plan the message and the
plan for the emotion can be really
helpful.
>> That's really helpful. Thank you very
much.
>> Excellent. Very good. All right, let me
now take one more question from one of
our team that helps bring the show. I'd
like to bring Greg in. Greg is so
helpful, particularly on all the
technical aspects of our show. Greg,
good to see you. Thanks for being here.
I'd love to hear your question.
>> Wonderful to see you, too. Thanks.
Thanks, Matt, and hello, listeners.
Okay, my question is this, and I think
the listeners will have noticed this
listening to the show that you have a
superpower.
And that superpower is summarizing.
You have an incredible ability to do it.
You've listened to somebody speak and
you repeat back what they've said in in
your own words, and what that does for
us as listeners of the show, I think it
clarifies what's been said and helps us
to understand and remember.
And having worked with you now for a
couple of years, what it does for me
personally is it shows empathy.
It shows that you are listening to what
I'm saying, and so that feels good as
the person receiving that summary back.
And so my question to you is this, what
is going through your mind right now
as you are listening to my long rambling
preamble to my question so that you can
summarize what I have said?
>> So, you're really asking about
paraphrasing and and how I go about
doing it. As I listen to our guests, as
I listen to you, as I will be listening
and reading the questions from others
today, I am always asking myself,
"What's the bottom line of what the
person is saying?
And why and how is it relevant, in the
case of the interviews on the show, to
the audience?" So, as you're speaking,
I'm listening intently and I'm
constantly thinking to myself, "What's
the bottom line? What's the key point
the person is making?" I might get it
wrong, and that's where paraphrasing
actually helps because not only does it
validate you, it says, "I've heard you."
But, it also allows me to validate that
I got it right because if I miss it, you
could correct me. Paraphrasing not only
is a tool for connection, it's a
fidelity check. Fidelity is the accuracy
and clarity of the transmission of the
information. So, it's a wonderful tool
to connect and it's a wonderful tool to
make sure I'm hearing what people are
saying. I encourage all of you to
practice. At the end of every one of our
episodes, I would love for you to take a
moment and say, "What was the bottom
line key takeaway from that episode for
me, you as the listener?" And then, we
hope you put it into practice. But, by
training that skill, you can really help
yourself connect and make sure you're
accurately hearing information. How did
I do, Greg? I paraphrase that well?
>> You paraphrased it well. I was fishing
for more compliments, but uh I'll take
that.
>> Greg, you do amazing work as does the
rest of the team. Thank you for the
question.
Please share tips for beginning speakers
to seem unplanned in using gestures
while having actually planned and
rehearsed ahead. Oh, well, I've got a
little teaser for you. Uh
coming up actually right around the time
this episode, our 300th episode, airs, I
am interviewing Vanessa Van Edwards. And
Vanessa is an amazing researcher as well
as a presenter on communication issues
and we talked exactly about this issue.
So you'll hear the dialogue and
discussion there, but I'll give you a
summary here.
Uh gestures are really important.
Gestures are for the audience a way that
we can engage in a multimodal way.
Our brains are primarily designed to
take in the world visually.
There are more parts of the human brain
dedicated to vision, seeing, than to the
other senses. So while I'm speaking, you
have a an area in your brain that's
verbal, but there's a lot more that's
visual. So when I'm gesturing in a
consistent way, I'm actually reinforcing
what I'm saying because you're seeing it
and you're hearing it and I'm activating
a lot of brain regions for doing it. Now
for me, as a communicator, the one in
this case speaking, gestures actually
offload cognitive load. So when I
gesture, I actually make it easier for
myself to think. So if my gestures are
consistent with what I'm saying, it
actually helps me be clearer. It
increases my processing fluency. And for
you, it makes it easier to understand
because I'm engaging multiple brain
systems. So gesturing is really
important.
How do we practice it though so we don't
look robotic?
First we do not want to script gestures.
I do not want to start a speech in a
very scripted way because it looks
scripted. It looks disingenuous. It
looks inauthentic.
So how do we practice?
For many people who are just beginning
to work on gestures, my biggest bit of
advice is play charades as you speak.
Charades is a game where we don't use
words to describe things. We use our
gestures. If I'm standing up giving a a
sales pitch and say this is a big
opportunity, I gesture big. I wouldn't
say this is a big opportunity and
gesture small. Uh if I was saying
profits will likely rise, I do a gesture
that demonstrates rising. So, you're
mimicking or mirroring the words in your
gestures. And if you're not comfortable
with gesturing or you want to learn to
gesture more, starting with descriptive
gestures is easiest.
Then you graduate to what are called
emphatic gestures. And if you've ever
watched me speak, you see I use a lot of
these. Emphatic gestures are gestures
that add emphasis. They don't have an
immediate correlate to what I'm saying.
A former student of mine actually
introduced a technique to me for
practicing this as he was preparing for
a presentation he had in my class.
What he would do is he would audio
record himself, do like a voice memo of
him presenting his presentation. Not
memorized, not reading it, he would just
talk it through and record it. And then
he would put earbuds in, he would stand
up, and he would listen to himself
saying the words, and he would just walk
around practicing the gestures that he
might say as those words were delivered.
Not to script them, but to give him the
cognitive bandwidth. He didn't have to
think of what to say because he was just
listening to himself say it. He could
actually think about his gestures and
say, "You know, at this point I should
probably do a really big gesture. At
this point, maybe I should move because
it's a transition." So, he was freeing
up his brain to think about how he
wanted to gesture because he didn't need
to use all of that cognitive bandwidth
to think of what he was saying. So, this
is a great way to practice. It's an
intermediate step. You absolutely need
to practice speaking and gesturing, but
you can before that, you can do this
technique of recording it, listening to
it while you're presenting. So, those
are all ways to hone and develop
gesturing. Start with descriptive
gestures, know that gestures are helping
you and your audience, and record
yourself and practice listening to that
recording.
So, there you have it, our 300th
episode. Thank you again for listening
and your support. Do me a huge favor and
be sure to subscribe and rate us. Also,
follow us on LinkedIn, TikTok, and
Instagram.
If you like celebration episodes, please
take a listen to our 250th episode all
about managing conflict.
This episode was produced by Catherine
Reed, Shelby Merryweather, Ryan Campos,
and me, Matt Abrahams. Our music is from
Floyd Wonder with special thanks to
Podium Podcast Company. Please find us
on YouTube and wherever you get your
podcasts. Check out faster smarter.io
for deep dive videos,
>> [music]
>> English language learning content, and
our newsletter.
Please consider joining our Think Fast
Talk Smart learning community at
fasterSmarter.io/learning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, an AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
that's fasterSmarter.io/learning
to become part of our Think Fast Talk
Smart learning community.